The directory entry has one dirty bit
that indicates that the block is dirty
in some cache in the system, and for
every cache in the system, the directory
entry has one bit that indicates whether
the block is present in that cache.
If the presence bit is 1 for
a particular cache,
that means that we think that
cache has a copy of the block.
If the presence bit is 0,
that means that we know for
sure that that cache does not have
the block in a state that is not I.
So let's say we have one
block caches at core 0 and
1, and let's say this is
the directory entry for block B,
where this is the dirty bit and
these are the presence bits for
cores zero, one, two, three,
four, five, six, and seven.
So, this is an eight core system, so
we need eight bits to represent
presence of the block in the caches.
Initially, the block is not dirty and
is not present in any of the caches.
Let's say that core zero
reads from the block B.
The block is not in its cache, so it's
treated like it's in the invalid state.
We put the read request out.
Normally, this read request
will be put out on the bus.
And because no other cache has this,
the memory would respond.
But now we don't have snooping anymore.
So all requests for
a block would be sent first to
the home slice of the block.
And we determine what is the home slice
by looking at the address of the block.
Different blocks are distributed
among different slices so
that we get an even load
between the slices.
So let's say we determine that for
block B, this is the slice where we go,
and once the request gets there,
we look at the directory entry for it.
The directory entry says that the block
is not anywhere in the system.
So now we can get the data from memory,
and send the data back to the cache 0,
and
we need to tell the cache 0 everything
that the bus would normally tell it.
So we tell it that it
has exclusive access,
because there are no other sharers.
And we give it the data.
That response gets back to cache 0,
and now if it has the exclusive state,
it can put the block in that state and
put the data for B here.
When the directory sends
the data to Cache 0,
it changes the presence bit for
that cache to 1.
Also, we sent the data
with exclusive access.
If cache 0 modifies the data, it doesn't
have to notify the directory back, so
we also set the dirty bit.
The dirty bit here will
not cause a write-back.
It will cause us to find if
a cache needs to do a write-back.
So now why does this
work better than a bus?
Well because while cache 0 was doing
this with this directory slice,
cache 1 could have done
something like that for
another block, with another directory
slice, completely independently.
However, if cache 1 tries to write to
B at about the same time when read
B was occurring, we would send our write
request to the same directory entry.
And now, between these two messages,
the directory controller
needs to select one.
In this case it shows
read request first, so
officially, this read
happened before this write.
So the core here gets to
read the block B, and
only then, the write gets
processed by the directory.
So when this write request arrives here,
again, this write request would be
placed on the bus, seen by this cache.
As a result,
this cache would invalidate, and
we will get the block
in the modified state.
With the directory, we send the request
to the directory controller.
It sees that the block is present and
possibly dirty in this case, cache 0.
So what now happens is
the directory forwards the write
request for
B to the caches that are present.
In this case it forwards it to cache 0.
Cache 0 now sees this request just as
if it was snooped from the bus, and
because it has the data in the exclusive
state it can choose to respond with
the data or it just may keep quiet and
confirm the invalidation.
So, what happens here is once the write
request has been given to this cache,
we need to send the acknowledgement,
at least, if not the data, back
to the directory controller that says
that we are done invalidating our copy.
So this point we have
invalidated our copy.
When the acknowledgement arrives here,
the directory controller
can change this to 0.
If the data didn't arrive,
then we can erase the dirty bit.
And now because we don't have the data
still, we will read the memory and
send the data to cache 1.
And because we are acknowledging a write
request, we again set the dirty bit,
and now the presence factor gets a 1 for
the bit that corresponds to cache 1,
and now we get to set M here and
write to the B here.
So as you can see, this is how the
caches can do their normal coherence,
but now instead of everybody
seeing everything,
that we need to send
a request to the directory,
which then sends out the messages
that need to be sent.
Only to those caches that
actually might have the block.
So if a block is shared
by only two cores,
then we will be only sending
a very few messages.
In contrast, the bus would force us to
basically broadcast to all of the cores.
So this also saves a lot of bandwidth
because we're using point to point
network links to send just this.
Meanwhile, other cores could be doing
something like this with another
directory entry,
completely independently over a network.